even think about that for any for at all
good but um you know so we got these
stories lined up this one took the lead
story that we're gonna talk about it's
kind of creepy it's from today
they found 42 oddly buried skeletons on
a farm in the UK and we and we could
just talk about it first but you know
what's crazy I got I got to do this
mm-hmm the corona virus is really deadly
it's like a oh it's way worse oh yeah
every night I did then found new stuff
yeah and I think I did a segment on my
my news gel my second Channel mm-hmm and
I think it's just like it just bears
repeating so we can just open up with
this listen man there's an app there's
now a story I think it's from Fox News
you know maybe was Fox it experts are
warning of a pandemic they're like it's
gonna happen it's not yeah it's gonna be
all over it's gonna be everywhere and a
lot of people I keep seeing these memes
pop up these tweets and people are
laughing they're like the flu is already
killed 10,000 people oh my god and I was
on that train I admit it
yeah I was like come on everybody the
flu so much worse what are you doing and
now we know that it's traveling as fast
as the flu and it's mortality rate is 10
to 20 times higher that is a lot so it's
like the corona virus is is way way bad
yeah it's it is a scary thing but you
were just on drugs so you don't have to
you know your caffeine that's what I
mean you can't Fein overdose so I don't
know I thought that was just like
interesting to kind of bring up before
we just jump into a stories that the
stories about mysterious dead bodies
serious dead bodies
so yeah let's check us out so we
actually have two stories in this vein
it's kind of weird and we got a couple
mysteries for you today but this one I
thought was kind of just I don't know
I'm kind of I'm kind of ambivalent I'm
like a bunch of dead bodies appearing on
a farm because I kind of I'm kind of
like what's the what's the word
desensitized just like 42 oddly buried
that's what gets me possibly buried
because that's a mass grave well they
would have said that don't you think
like it's like a serial killer in the
makes it's so different from you know
finding a mass grave because that's
really what I see but they're oddly
buried skeletons what does that mean you
know are they it's like listen okay
they're not
opposed to be there right right it's not
a cemetery right so no matter why
they're buried it's odd yeah all right
well let's let's let's reread this from
live live science or that live science I
don't know it's from just ten hours ago
they say excavation for the construction
of a retirement community in the rural
UK recently unearthed 42 skeletons and
shallow graves that had their hands tied
behind their backs all right we just
stepped into it's beyond odd yeah that's
that's weird these people were murdered
but how the bodies ended up there and
who they might represent represent what
is it who they might be remain unknown
contract okay are they like really
really old contract archaeologists
working with the builders have yet to
provide local officials with a report
about the remains and the country
residents are calling for answers local
news site the Milton Keynes citizen
reported on January 28th the remains
were discovered in December on West End
farm in Buckingham England after
developer Brio retirement living holding
broke ground for 72 new apartments for
retirees according to MK citizen the
shallowness of the graves and the fact
the skeletons hands were bound suggested
they were prisoners of some kind said
district and town councillor Robin
stuttering they could date from
anglo-saxon times okay so this is super
old oh wow I'm talking about like a
major archeological find
yeah that's that's a when there were
killings in Buckingham or during the
Civil War which also saw casualties
stretch Barry told MK citizen okay so it
doesn't it might not necessarily be that
old but yes the old I don't know
anything about the UK I don't I don't I
think we're legally obligated to not
care about the UK after the Revolution
so like I reject your news I don't know
I am reading about this no okay like
we're like after like World War I think
one because we had to kept getting
involved in their affairs now it's okay
to talk about some things but as for the
anglo-saxons during the British you know
the English Civil War whatever was
called I don't know whatever but let's
read so they say they could be criminals
who were hanged on the gallows in the
town representatives of Bucks County
Council's Archaeological Service said
that they were aware of the find but
have yet to receive further information
about the discovery of the skeletons MK
citizen reported we are unable to
comment
the archeological remains discovered at
the West End farm site at present as we
are still awaiting a report detailing
the results from the archeological
contractors a spokesman spokesperson
told MK citizen analysis of the
excavation would include descriptions of
any artifacts found in the graves as
well as skeletons genders ages and
details of how they died
all of this would help determine who the
people were and how they ended up buried
together in these farmland mass graves
but it could be months before BCAAs
receives such a report according to the
BBC this find is of great historical
significance to Buckingham and it should
not be hushed up stuck bury edit with
someone trying to hush it up I don't
know maybe because could you imagine if
you invested you know millions of
dollars into building a retirement home
or condos oh yeah and they're like we're
gonna have to stop you because of the
corpses that we found you're gonna be
alike this is now an archaeological site
oh that's even worse can't ever built
here oh yeah I see that happen though
you know yeah who knows what it kind of
reminds me of like you know like an old
80's movie where like the evil developer
is like I must destroy the
archaeological dig site to my
condominiums we gotta sweep it under
like cover it up mm-hmm so we actually
have in in in reading this you know my
first assumption when you first read the
story is like is there a serial killer
on the loose yeah up nope it's just the
British government shell out everybody
they just killed a bunch people bound
their hands behind their back but those
things happen right happened a long time
ago now we're basically completely
demonetized
talking about 42 hey it's science though
we're talking about an archeological dig
okay yeah but this got me thinking about
you know I ended up doing a search
looking into stories pertaining to I
guess just bodies horses and we found
this other story that's actually it's
it's from last year from the Atlantic no
one really knows what to do with all of
America's unclaimed corpses how many do
we have we have a lot and and states are
going to weird lengths to deal with
overcrowded marks but here's the thing I
don't talk about you know look okay so
we talked about the silly mystery you
know okay so maybe a cellar it's 42
people who are like bound it maybe they
don't know what happened okay something
happen in the Civil War maybe they're
rebels or whatever you call them but
what you know what I was thinking I was
driving down
some highway the other day and I can't
have no idea where it where it was and I
noticed that it was like the most oddly
placed cemetery next to some buildings
in a suburban environment okay and the
cemetery was as big as like a single
plot of land like like a house you know
like it like a couple you know a ten
thousand square feet maybe like an acre
or two I'm like so those corpses just
there forever that's a good point
like so I you know you ever see the
movie uh up yeah so it's the one where
like the it starts with the old guy and
he doesn't to give up his house right
and then like because his wife died or
whatever and then over time the city and
the skyscrapers build up around it oh
yeah like we're literally getting to the
point where skyscrapers and big cities
are being built on these tiny cemeteries
like in in in Manhattan in the financial
district you actually have the Trinity
Church and there's literally like two
cemeteries yeah right there's gonna be
as corpses there forever right it's like
this is officially unusable bodies what
would you suggest I don't know I'm just
saying like it's a crazy thought I'm
like right you know there's there's
small cemeteries like what I was gonna
get full what do you do you just say oh
we're full yeah right I've never been
I've never been fond of ceremonial
burial
yeah meaning I've always been more about
the Viking funeral you know put me in a
boat kick me to the ocean of fire a
flaming arrow yeah let me go to the
fishes so now we have this problem so
this is this was really interesting
because you know when thinking about
them finding these bodies and trying to
build something like I said that the
first thought was like oddly buried oh
is the murder right now it's like civil
war or something I started thinking like
what do we do when we have overcrowded
cemeteries like there's a finite amount
of space for dead people right sure well
they have those earth pods now that you
can be turned into a tree oh yeah they
put mushrooms on your something right
like that's cool I'd be a tree I'd be
down you're like technically a tree like
your star dust becomes a tree yeah but
let's read and see what this what's what
weird lengths the states are going to
deal with overcrowded morgues and they
got to put this weird creepy picture
like what is this alright yeah here we
go well - oh here we go they're giving
us the narrative they're not gonna tell
us what's going on there's gonna tell us
a story
classic Sarah Krebs is used to corpses
going missing what why why the detective
who works in the missing persons unit in
Detroit she has solved dozens of cases
by matching up disappeared people
two unidentified bodies left in state
custody but for older cases in which the
county was supposed to have buried the
body
Krebs says it's common for her to order
an exit xx' Meishan from the local
cemetery and discovered the bodies she's
looking for is not there what what so so
they were supposed to have buried it in
a spot but not dealing the bodies uh is
that you thinking well I mean
something's happening
well let's see what they say anywhere
from a few days to a few years later
those bones might turn up in a separate
burial plot what's what or in a or in a
box on a medical examiner's shelf or in
law enforcement evidence room or in a
county employees house I have multiple
multiple cases where we had thought the
body was buried and we found a couple of
days later that someone had it at home
so they're taking their work home oh
this is really what your face is so
shocked right now I the other person you
can't see is like my god I got to admit
like here's the thing
you know whenever out of sight out of
mind we really do live in our own worlds
yeah that's true that's like so I had
this idea once for a show because I was
I was at it I was at a Starbucks and I
saw this across the street and the
Starbucks was a wall and the wall had
blacks are arcing streaks on it and I
thought to myself I know exactly what
that is and no one else does and I can
see something on that wall no one else
can
they were skateboarding wall ride marks
the average person would look at it and
not even think twice like I said we
talked about last week about the ship
and the horizon and yeah if it's not so
it doesn't really never even thought
about this problem that people who work
at morgues are never like I'm gonna go
dig up this corpse and bring its bones
in my house I didn't know that was a
thing now you do hey that's why you know
you read it you know what I like about
doing this new show we're learning you
know it's almost like they they took the
body out of the like the case or the you
know whatever and before it got buried
because they're bearing it up and
realize what people who want these jobs
probably want them for a reason like
what do you think like there's somebody
being like when I grew up it's my dream
to just you know exhume dead bodies ooh
or or just bring him home with me and
yeah well that I know that's the secret
Exim ation is like well you know I got a
do it you think they have tea parties at
home them up weekend hold on hold on
they say they say they say the reason
for this morbid confusion is that the
United States is enduring a cadaver
pile-up medically medical exam sorry I'm
laughing medical examiners around the
country are being overrun with bodies
that no one comes to pick up a trend
that many coroner's attribute to the
nation's opioid epidemic got that got
really dark really fast you know okay
okay I'm sorry I got you know uh but
let's read drug overdose deaths
increased by ten percent from 2016 to
2017 largely driven by fentanyl's and
similar drugs according to the CDC now
what medical examiner's in cities such
as Detroit process dozens of new remains
each day and as crabbed has encountered
some of those bodies can slip onto the
writer okay well hold on hold on oh man
I'm gonna be much more sensitive to the
story about you know opioid addiction
and drug abuse and stuff yeah and that
was not what we were talking about okay
they're talking about graves right and
they open it up to exhume there's
nothing there right and they find it in
a different casket like it's somewhere
or at an employee's house yeah like
what's up with that not if you want to
if you want to talk about the pile up
and then you want to talk about how the
opioid problem is so bad these people
these victims are piling up that's free
I mean a 10% increase in a year that's a
lot man Wow
that's crazy especially for Detroit it
makes sense you know economic downturn
or whatever they see the bodies that
remain accounted for meanwhile float in
and out of state custody no one is quite
sure what to do with them the United
States has no uniform sister for
managing the unclaimed there is no
federal law outlining what steps to take
and many states do not have clear
procedures leaving individual Medical
Examiner's to make decisions about how
best to deal with the bodies as a result
examiner's without money to simply bury
or cremate the remains are resorting to
inventive and strange solutions not and
then I'm sorry man look I get it if you
like leave the bodies in the morgue yeah
but taking them home yeah that does not
have something totally different yeah
those people those people are just like
it's not my fault just you know there's
so many there's to me had to bring them
to my house I'm doing the office a favor
we're saving money taxpayer dollars
being saved to your guys among the
unclaimed bodies
in the United States some are the some
are the unidentified remains from
missing person cases like the ones Krebs
works on but the majority belong to
people who are estranged from their
family while they were alive according
to Kenneth Quinet an associate professor
at Indiana University Purdue University
Indianapolis who co-wrote one of the
only academic articles on unclaimed
bodies in most of these cases the
identity of the victim is known but
coroner's or funeral directors can't
contact the next of kin or the next of
kin was reached in either doesn't want
the body or can't afford to bury it the
unclaimed population skews poor and
homeless not sad man you know I I but
I've never been a fan again of like
plotted ceremonial barrier a burial
mm-hmm I always much more related to
Frank from It's Always Sunny when he was
like just throw me in the trash he's
like this they were like they wrote on a
tombstone or something like he was an
awful father and it's like this is what
you're doing with me when I die it's
throw me the trash and I'm like yeah I
never really cared put me in the like
Viking funeral you know yeah I'm not
gonna be in that body after I die
I mean maybe that's a scary thing wasn't
there there's like a Tales from the
Crypt episode you've what you watch
tales gonna cut before I remember it
yeah dude I think I think one of the
most like nightmarish hell possibilities
oh I said the H word is I'm okay
whatever was uh the guy dies
yeah then he's still in his body and he
still feels everything he says he's
anything he just can't do it he can't
move and so he's like witnessing he was
murdered and like that is a frightening
premise I think that was I think that
was Tales from the Crypt I don't know I
was like really young when I saw it it's
but I was like that's three seriously
and then like I guess the woman his wife
kills him oh no his wife kills him and
then like the guy she was cheating with
kills her and then they're both like
just stuck in their corpses and like man
what if what if that and is what happens
that's we should actually do what
happens after you die segment not just
like jump off of this so well I'll tell
you what we've we've gone a little bit
on this yeah I think we get the idea I
don't want to be callous because I
definitely you know I'm concerned about
this they say New Yorkers bared more
than a million unclaimed bodies Wow yeah
then over I don't know how long oh is
that it says I don't know I'm saying I
don't it doesn't say exactly oh yeah
body forms oh do tennis while ten
he gives some unclaimed cadavers to body
farms where researchers study
decomposition I'm actually ok with that
like I search yeah it my body take for
science sure you know shove some
mushrooms you know what about thing
where if you're an organ donor they
might not save you oh that's a whole
other segment yeah yeah I know we could
talk about that well she's the fancy
doctor over there what is what are you
saying they don't know body farms are
really cool and no they do not choose
not to save you lying she's part of the
conspiracy I hope she was telling us she
knew all about coronavirus so so yeah a
lot of people are worried that if you're
an organ donor they're gonna be like
well we could save them but we could
save six others no no but they already
know no no it's we could save them but
look at them juicy organs all right all
right all right we're making fun of
people so let's wrap this up they say
still many Medical Examiner's don't know
NamUs exists so this is the created
database as a search tool where they can
come up with bodies and find their
family until any sort of procedure is
standardized unclaimed bodies in cities
that see a high number of dead will
continue to float from office to office
home to home refrigerated truck to
refrigerated truck when Krebs needs to
test the DNA of an unclaimed body for a
missing persons case she will have to
keep racing from building to building in
search of the transient dead and she
won't be surprised to find the bones she
has been looking for in a glass display
at a local university she solved cold
cases that way nothing that is creepy
Wow
could you imagine being like a
university where you're like we're
accepting this body it's like that was
murder victim went missing and you have
that yeah we need that to stop the crime
that happened that literally happy years
ago all right
we're happy
you